we're going to begin along the gulf
coast where thousands as you know are
preparing their homes for not one but
two
major storms the governor of louisiana
has told residents to prepare to
shelter in place for at least 72
hours yikes tropical weather systems
marco and laura are their names are both
expected to hit the state this week
laura has already devastated parts of
the dominican republic
and haiti over the weekend at least 11
people have been killed
wcbs tv chief weather caster that's
lonnie quinn is tracking this
tracking all of this for us lonnie good
morning again although things aren't
sounding so good
no it's it's not a great looking
situation for the gulf coast good
morning to you gail good morning
everybody i'll say this much
in the last two three hours marco has
gotten
markedly weaker i mean it's down to 50
mile per hour winds with each passing
hour now
marco is going to get weaker it's about
let's say 85 miles from the mouth of the
mississippi river
laura is going to do nothing but get
stronger laura right now is 65 miles per
hour winds
by tomorrow at 2 o'clock in the
afternoon marco is going to be skirting
somewhere along the shoreline of
louisiana or texas
laura is right in the middle of the gulf
of mexico now a category one
by the time you get to wednesday at two
o'clock
in the after and in the afternoon we're
now up to a category two
it's just offshore of the same area
that marco has just tramped over right
and if you can zoom in tight here i want
to show you
what the european model is saying
everybody wants to know what does a
european say where's landfall going to
be
well the ensemble model for the european
is right here that bright yellow line
right into galveston bay galveston bay
look that's a bad place for hurricane to
go all that water gets pushed into the
bay
there's nowhere for it to flow except up
and over the banks
and flood the area so we've got to watch
this one very carefully guys
that's the latest i'll update you as i
get more information let's go back to
you
all right lonnie thank you very much